[Musique]
on s'excuse sincèrement
retard annulation passager coincé
pendant des heures dans des avions des
trains ou des hôtels à l'étranger le
mauvais temps a imposé à plusieurs
Canadiens des vacances des fêtes
particulièrement difficiles une
situation inacceptable pour le Comité
permanent des transports de la Chambre
des communes qui a tenté de faire la
lumière sur ce qui s'est passé Julie
vignolin est député de Beauport
québécois et porte-parole aussi du
tourisme il est avec nous en studio
bonne année bonne année merci d'être
avec nous vous étiez jeudi à la réunion
du Comité des transports vous avez
entendu les témoignages qu'est-ce que
vous en retenez
que le mauvais temps au Canada a le dos
très large j'en retiens également que
certains transporteurs ont fait leur
devoir de planification en vue de la
campagne qui était annoncée c'était pas
une surprise et j'en retiens surtout que
il y a une révision de la chambre des
voyageurs le règlement de protection des
usagers aériens qui vont être faites
idéalement d'ici juin
parlons des problèmes en tant que tel
parce que vous êtes la météo à le dos
large il y a des compagnies qui ont pas
fait leur travail
lorsqu'on parle l'aéroport Montréal en
particulièrement été sévère envers
Sunwing et le manque de planification de
de présence sur le terrain de gens pour
répondre aux questions des passagers
puis pour recevoir ces passagers aussi
d'autres compagnies ont mieux gérer la
situation sur le terrain quelle est la
différence
lorsque vous avez entendu entre ceux qui
ont bien fait les choses et ceux qui ont
moins bien fait les choses ou mal fait
les choses le nombre d'usagers est
satisfaits la vitesse de réponse
et où les usagers ont fini leur nuit
finalement donc plusieurs plusieurs ont
fini leur nuit à l'aéroport
d'autres ont réussi à avoir des hôtels
grâce aux soutien de la compagnie
aérienne est-ce que les règles fédérales
sont trop l'axe sont trop souples est-ce
qu'on laisse trop de marge de manœuvre
au transporteur c'est la grande question
qu'on s'est posée qu'on a posé également
un comité parce que ici on a trois
catégories de de problèmes si on veut on
a celles qui sont imputables au
transporteur celles qui sont imputables
aux transporteurs mais nécessaires en
fonction de sécurité et celles qui ne
sont pas imputables aux transporteur
dans le cas de la deuxième
impeccable au transporteur mais
nécessaire en cas de sécurité le
transporteur en utilisant la clause de
sécurité ne pas à indemniser les
passagers
et voilà il faut l'utiliser souvent puis
la manière que la charte est faite c'est
que c'est pas au transporteur de
démontrer qu'il y a vraiment une cause
de sécurité qui nécessite l'annulation
ou le retard c'est tout passager qui va
faire la plainte qui doit démontrer que
il y avait pas vraiment de clauses de
sécurité ou que la clause a été invoquée
à tout-venant
transporteurs réunis là dessus durant
les travaux du Comité de jeudi vous
dites quoi est-ce qu'ils ont
l'impression d'assurer cette clause là
disons que la réponse c'était plutôt
floue et on faut s'entendre que la
sécurité des passagers c'est important
c'est primordial pour tout le monde dans
un aéroport et de recherche
pas au passager à démontrer que il y a
le droit de compensation que ce soit au
transporteur à démontrer qu'il y a
utilisé la clause nécessaire par ce site
de sécurité adéquatement déjà là
d'augmenter les sanctions parce que
actuellement les sanctions pour une
personne physique c'est 1000 à 5000
dollars puis pour la personne morale
qu'est le transporteur c'est entre 5000
et 25000 dollars aux États-Unis ça va
jusqu'à 400 000 dollars
parce qu'on n'a pas le même bassin
d'usager ici qu'aux États-Unis
cependant les sanctions doivent avoir un
effet dissuasif et on a l'impression que
c'est pas le cas actuellement je pense
que le Bloc québécois est d'avis que on
devrait s'inspirer surtout de ce qui se
fait en Europe c'est bien le cas oui
c'est le cas c'est quoi la différence
mais en Europe il y a deux clauses au
lieu de trois comme je vous expliquais
tantôt c'est soit que c'est de la faute
du transporteur ou ça ne l'est pas c'est
tout c'est tout la clause de sécurité
est pas incluse comme échappatoire en
guillemets c'est de ta faute que ce soit
une question de sécurité ou pas c'est de
ta faute ou ça l'est pas et la
présentation est beaucoup plus simple
pour les usagers pour comprendre quels
sont leurs droits aussi
la demande est assez simple aussi et
plus convivial que ce qui se fait ici le
fils des transports du Canada un arriéré
à l'heure actuelle de 30
000 plaintes à traiter on fait quoi pour
ça
c'est la question que j'ai posé
justement à l'office jeudi à savoir
est-ce que vous avez besoin plus de
ressources est-ce qu'on a besoin de
simplifier le processus est-ce que la
les
transporteurs doivent avoir une plus
grande charge dans ce processus là parce
que là les les gens se tournent presque
de recherche vers le fils parce que le
transporteur leur envoi quasi
systématiquement des réponses négatives
à leur demande je vous ai senti la
semaine dernière
optimiste ouverte à attendre de voir ce
que monsieur algabrale est fait comme
modification parce qu'il y a une
ouverture de la part du gouvernement de
faire des modifications pour rendre le
processus plus simple et
imposer aux compagnies aériennes de
rendre les comptes plus rapidement vous
lui donnez jusqu'à quand pour réaliser
tout ça je vais lui donner en fait il
s'est donné lui-même cette ce cette
échéancier là qui est pour la fin juin
c'est à dire la fin de la session
printanière je vais venir là merci
beaucoup merci à vous